We Begin this NewsHour with an exclusive
report from Haiti where a powerful gang
leader is accusing politicians of
fueling violence through their support
for armed groups Jimmy cherizier leads a
Federation of nine gangs but says
they're simply fighting to provide basic
services and security for people however
the former police officer has been
accused of human rights violations and
killing civilians terisabo met him in
Haiti's Capital Porto Prince
and family and allies just one of the
many gangs vying for control of photo
Prince or the places where our Jedi
family it is run by former police
officer Jamie sharifier also known as
barbecue he took us to the front line of
his Urban Battleground he says a rival
gang is on the other side
it's unfortunate we have to call some
Haitians enemies but the Haitian
oligarchs and politicians give them guns
and ammunition to destroy our
communities his men are extremely
cautious wary of an attack from the
other side
has created what is known as the G9 it's
a Federation of gangs and it's one of
the most powerful here in the capital
they're fighting for control of the
territory on the other side of this wall
is the neighborhood of Bel-Air that
they've been trying to control
but chericia says the G9 is not a gang
he says he's fighting to help provide
security and basic services to the
people left behind by the government
there's a difference between a gang and
an armed group we have an ideology we
have a vision to see Haiti with all the
services with drinkable water Schools
jobs and with security
his opponents accuse his groups of
killing civilians and setting houses on
fire hundreds have fled fearing for
their lives the U.N U.S and Canada
impose sanctions on him last year
prime minister Ariel Enrique has asked
for international assistance to fight
the gangs
says most are funded by those running
the country
the PM's not asking for foreign troops
to come to the country they want foreign
forces to protect them from the crimes
they have committed several times the
un's intervened in Haiti and you see
that the result is always zero
wanted to show us the difference between
the areas controlled by him and other
parts of Porto Prince
he says there are no shortages of food
here and the streets are clean because
he pays for it
Jimmy is the state in this part of
Port-au-Prince
in the past few weeks people have turned
against the gangs in the country killing
suspected gang members on the streets
the movement is known as
says he supports them saying the time
has come for people to fight back
for the prince
so Theresa filed that exclusive report
from Haiti we can now speak to her she's
joining us from Porter Prince Teresa the
U.N wants to send an international force
is that something that the Haitian
people want right now
tell you where I am right now there's
not much people left here and this is
what large parts of Porter Prince look
like as people have been forced to flee
their homes because of the fighting that
has been going on here if you see all of
this area it is completely empty we have
gone to with the people that were living
here have gone and they have shortages
of food of water children are getting
sickness
humanitarian situation here on the
ground what's happening here in this
neighborhood of Bel Air that has been at
a fight taken away for the giant group
that we just saw the report with this is
what happened look at this houses it's
all been set on fire if I can open this
door here all of this was on fire I am
told that hundreds of people
here
were forced to flee so when you talk to
people about what they want in their
country is they would like to see the
situation change they're tired of the
killings of the kidnappings that have
been gone of the rapes that have spiked
in this past months here in Haiti they
want change they would like to see some
type of a force that will support the
Haitian National Police in order so it
is them that are fight back against the
possibility of international
mostly because of what happened here
in 2017 and then they helped pacify some
parts of the country all right I'll have
to move away from Theresa because we are
having issues there are Distortion
issues with Theresa and her audio and
video we do apologize uh for that
connection uh but let's talk about Haiti
and bring in Ravina sham Dasani she's
the spokeswoman for the UN Human Rights
office joining us from Geneva thank you
so much for your time with us on Al
Jazeera so I know that the U.N put out a
report back in February warning if a
spike in gang violence and gross human
rights abuses at the time what has the
U.N been doc been able to document
recently and what can you tell us about
the situation in Haiti
sadly the situation has gone from bad to
worse
um so far this year so between January
and the end of April we documented one
thousand nearly 1 500 killings as a
result of gang violence I mean this is a
situation that's akin to an armed
conflict situation and in just the past
five days from the 10th to the 15th of
May I have reports of 49 killings in
addition to that the new development
that we've seen last month is that
people are taking law the law into their
own hands um there's a lot of vigilante
so-called Justice going on which means
that gang members or presumed gang
members are now being lynched and
murdered and this of course is just
feeding a further cycle of violence
where competing gangs sometimes take
advantage of these vigilante groups to
Target the other gang so again we're
seeing a cycle of violence that's
showing no sign of ending how worrying
is all of this
it's incredibly worrying I mean as was
just described by the speaker who came
just before me people are living in a
nightmarish scenario
um and there's very little hope so
they're taking the Law into their own
hands which of course is not going to
help long term we have been pleading to
the International Community to step in
to provide some kind of a support Force
for Haiti to support the Haitian police
and the Haitian judicial institutions to
take care of the situation right I
wonder if you can elaborate a little bit
more on what exactly you mean when you
talk about this the support Force I mean
what does it look like and when you put
that to members of the International
Community what sort of response have you
been getting
so the Haitian police is not managing
the situation well they are
under-resourced there are Decades of
corruption um you know Decades of ill
and ill-equipped police force they need
support they cannot manage this on their
own and the people realize this which is
why they're taking the Law into their
own hands thus worsening the situation
judicial institutions in Haiti need
support there's just too much for them
there are as I said 1 500 killings just
in the course of four months carrying
out investigations preserving evidence
carrying out prosecutions all of that
needs a lot of support as well what we
are asking the International Community
to do is to step in now this will need
to be a haitian-led process but they
cannot accomplish they cannot win this
um this you know against the cycle of
violence without the support of the
International Community
unfortunately the response of the
International Community so far has been
lukewarm
um there's been very little appetite
um to really support Haiti in the way
that it needs to be supported but we are
going to continue to call for such
support right but if the root causes of
the problems in Haiti are not addressed
then then then it'll be difficult to to
sort of solve the problems won't it
because you have a country which is
mired in poverty for one as well as a
lack of basic services
absolutely you're absolutely right this
has to be a multi-pronged approach as
well where there's violence going on
Extreme violence um that's leading to
killings rapes kidnappings on a grand
scale that does need to be addressed but
at the same time the root causes of this
violence need to be addressed the
poverty the um corruption
um the the failure of the state to
provide for the basic needs of the
people so that the people are sometimes
forced to even turn to gangs for support
all of those root causes need to be
addressed as well and that is the
responsibility of the state to address
those problems okay we'll leave it there
we thank you so much for speaking to us
from Geneva